when you can go as a man and get a drug
that causes you to lactate which allows
you then to breastfeed your child and
that milk because of the drugs you have
to take actually causes heart problems
in a child and the CDC and everybody
else isn't going we gotta stop this
because this is evil which it is now
we're really in trouble now what's
happening is we are embracing actual
Insanity when you have men who can go to
women's prisons and get two women
pregnant before they get moved you say
you're a woman for three months and you
have balls and a beard and get put into
a woman's prison I don't know what the
we're doing anymore there are
certain things I'm willing to fight for
and I mean you're my enemy
I don't want to meet you halfway this is
why you say how did I come out of the
closet you want to call me right wing
you want to call me a conservative I'm a
proud conservative now because that's
the kind of sh I'm not going to
compromise on